Don't get me wrong, the newer, Grittier version of Batman is fine and all,
but I definitely miss the endless stream of Robin's bizarre catch-phrases from the 1960s.
"Holy uncanny photographic mental processes!"
"Holy priceless collection of a truscan snood!"
"Holy interplanetary yardstick!"
Oh. Oh. Let me try one! Uhh... Holy Robin focused online conspiracy theory video, Batman.
Did I... did I do it right? *Punches Robin Matpat in the face* *POW*
*Film Theory intro plays*
*Film Theory intro plays*  BOF!
*Film Theory intro plays*  ZZWAP
*Film Theory intro plays*
*Film Theory intro plays*  Whack!
*Film Theory intro plays* Thwack!
*Film Theory intro plays* BONK!!!
*Film Theory intro ends*
Holy Film Theory Internet.
Welcome to the show where we lay our investigative cards on the table and the jokers are always wild.
WOOHOO!
Seamless Segway alert
Joker, the clown prince who needs no introductions
And seriously when I say he needs no introductions,
He literally doesn't need any introduction, there are just somethings that don't need to be re-explained Batman V Superman
Plus I already talked about him plenty of times in my theories around the release of Suicide Squad last year
Which if you haven't watched them yet hit you tooootally should by clicking the "i" icon in the right hand corner
and after doing all that research and getting myself super amped up to see the movie
and prove my theory , the Joker... was in like 5 minutes of it
My theories were 5 times longer than the amount of time that he actually ended up in the movie.
I mean, I guess I should be counting my lucky stars since that 5 minutes
is a full two minutes longer than Jimmy Olsen lasted in the entirety of this extended universe.
"Miss Lane. Jimmy Olsen, photographer."
*Gunshot*
But still, kinda of a let down.
In fact, from my perspective the most interesting part of this new DCEU Joker
has come from the fans, nay, the theorists.
You see, back before Suicide Squad hit theaters, HECK, even before Batman V Superman hit theaters
Online theorists were guessing that the Joker wasn't quite who he said he was
That he wasn't just some off-the-street criminal mastermind like he's been in
every other cinematic incarnation
But that he was instead Batman's favorite Boy Wonder, Robin.
Robin, who had somehow been transformed into a psychotic madman
and for those of you who think you've already heard this theory, well..
Stick around because I think you're going to be surprised by this one.
Now, as far as I can tell this fan series started gathering evidence with a Reddit post from Jason-G169
back in 2015 who started analyzing all the promotional materials around holes in these movies
and legitimately there ARE a LOT of weird coincidences here: The bird tattoo on the Joker's arm,
the way Joker holds his cane in the Suicide Squad poster being similar to how Robin's suit
is positioned holding his lance in Batman V Superman,
the bullet holes in the Robin suit hanging in the Batcave
matching strange dots on Jared Leto's shoulders and promo shots for Suicide Squad
And the fact that in the video game Arkham Knight,
one of Batman's former Robins has a scar of a J on his face left there by the Joker,
a scar that just so happens to be in the same placement as the tattoo the Joker has in Suicide Squad.
Legitimately when you look at all that evidence laid out there's a fair amount of to go off of
But then the buzz kill train named David Ayer, director of Suicide Squad *WHOO WHOOOO!!*
rolled into the station and killed the theory DEAD.
When asked what the most outlandish thing he'd heard about the movie was, he responded with this:
"That the Joker is Jason Todd." (Interviewer) "Really!?" "That ain't the case."
Now, if you're NOT a Batman super fan, let me catch you up: Jason Todd in the comics is one of the
three main characters to have taken on the mantle of Robin over the years and I say "ONE OF"
because just like there've been multiple Jokers so too have there been multiple Robins.
You have the original Dick Grayson who eventually moves on from being
Batman's sidekick and turns into the hero Nightwing. Jason Todd is the next Robin.
At least until the Joker kidnaps him, beats him with a crowbar and blows him up in a warehouse.
*O-O-O-OVERKILL!!*
And then there's Tim Drake who tries to alleviate Batman's depression about
Jason Todd's murder by becoming the new Robin.
it's also worth noting that all three of them have, at one point or another in the comics
turned into the joker
So the idea of one of these characters turning into a tatted out jugalo isn't as absurd as it might seem
turning into mister J is like a write of passage for the  boy wonder,
right next to stop crime in a green speedo
in the comic, dark knight strikes again, Dick Grason
is fired for bieng robin and becomes the joker, Jason Todd after getting
killed in a death in the family by the joker, gets
gets resurrected via Lazarus pit
because, Hey! if you've got a pit that'll revive your dead
well, you use dat thing
upon his return, he takes on the role of the villian
RED HOOD
Which just so happens to be the Joker's original criminal identity
And then theres tim drake, who in the 2000 movie Batman Beyond Return Of The Joker,
Got himself kidnapped and brainwashed by the OG Joker, who then implants a micro chip into his neck
that mutates his DNA to make him into a Joker clone.
He is litteraly a werewolf , exept for hair, he has white clown makeup, and a killer laugh.
*KILLER LAUGH *
Get it ... look im not saying that all of this makes a whole lot of sense just that is a thing that conically happens in this series like every other month to the robin character,
but still i know what your thinking... WHY AM I STILL TALKING!
We already herd David air debunk this theory
So outside of my love for hiding under comforters in the middle of hotel rooms in NewYork city because im recording this on the road
Why am i wasting so much time recording this thing?
Well listen again to what he says... "that the joker is Jason Tod... it aint the case hes not".
Notice David Air didn't say that the joker wasn't robin he said that the joker wasn't Jason Tod.
But as we just went over there are at least three different robins and when you actually look at all the evidence put together across he d.c.e.u the much more likely scenario is that this version of the joker is actually Tim Drake  robin number three
So get ready as bat pat? straps on his utility belt we haven't a moment to waist so quick to the theory mobile
would you like to know more?